[Music]
welcome back to street talk
conolihi is a walking encyclopedia
of ai alignment and artificial general
intelligence knowledge most of science
of doing science is
about taste conor thinks the
intelligence explosion
is near he thinks that artificial
general intelligence is a bit like
climate change but worse even harder
problems
even shorter deadlines and even worse
consequences for the future these
problems are
incredibly hard and nobody
knows what to do about it how can we
make the world a better place how can we
ensure that humans get what they want
and that whatever we become in the far
future the other races of the speed of
the galaxy if they exist
are proud of what we've become we
started by speaking about some of the
different schools of thought
in ai alignment research miri is
basically trying to develop this for
intelligence how can we reason about
this
in a way that will apply to potentially
future
super intelligent systems we touched on
the core concept of intelligence many
times in today's conversation
i take a very practical approach i say
intelligence is the ability to solve
problems
in a way it's a cul-de-sac for us to get
bogged down in defining intelligence and
debating whether or not current systems
are intelligent because stuart russell
said
the primary concern is not spooky
emerging consciousness
but simply the ability to make high
quality decisions
gpt3 was recently released by openai
to much fanfare and hype but is it
really intelligent
and can it really reason have you ever
talked to a school kid
after they you know wrote an essay
there's no understanding
they have no idea it's just
regurgitation it's just babbling i think
it's an open problem whether humans are
intelligent or not
that is the specific argument that i
made at least wasn't that gpt3 isn't
intelligent but that gpt3 isn't doing
whatever you might call reasoning this
is one of the main problems in
intelligence
because as you pointed out even in
humans you can teach kids
how to do their times tables and what
the rules are for multiplication
and they can use their system too but
after a while
they will just memorize the results and
they'll shortcut and this
this problem of imitation is pervasive
and neural networks are interesting
because if you look at alphago i said
earlier almost
taking the piss a little bit that it's
memorized all of the
moves but of course it hasn't because
there are an incredibly high number of
possible moves what it's actually done
is it's
through self-play it's generated a whole
bunch of data and then
it's created this hierarchical entangled
representation of all of these different
board positions and then
inside that convex hull of possible
positions it's cleverly interpolating
between them
that's exactly what gpt does but connor
makes an
absolutely huge call about gpt3
i think gp3 is artificial hei i think
gpt3 is as intelligent as human
and i think that actually is probably
more intelligent in the human in a
restricted way
in a very specific way i also believe
that in many ways it is more purely
intelligent than humans are
i think that humans are approximating
what gpt3 is doing not all vice versa
we don't know what gpt3 does we do not
know
the magic of touring universality means
that
even a very modestly powerful algorithm
can approximate
any other possible algorithm many of us
were talking past each other when we
used the word intelligence
maybe we should just stop using the word
intelligence completely
maybe it doesn't help us intelligence is
what marvin mincy called a suitcase word
you could pack all these different
definitions into it and they don't have
to be compatible
let's taboo the word intelligence no one
is allowed to say intelligence
for now instead we're going to try to
use different things we're going to use
like sample efficiency we use
computational efficiency performance
that would be a great advice i think for
the whole field
so there is a definition of intelligence
of compression there's this idea that
intelligence
is the compression the exploitation in
the structure of the space
of the search function is that a more
intelligent system
can reach a better approximation of the
correct answer in a smaller polynomial
amount of steps
back in 2017 connor thought that deep
learning was dead
i was convinced in 2017 that the bubble
has burst deep learning is
dead like why do we even research it are
you kidding me matrix multiplications
wow intelligence boys we did it it's
you know it seemed so preposterous i
looked at the brain and had all this
complexity i
came from neuroscience or watching one
of my first love was neuroscience
there have been plenty of naysayers
about gpt3 gary marcus is probably the
most well known
but conor thinks that gary is barking up
the wrong tree that gpt-3
is really intelligent and the way it
behaves is just a function of how it's
been formulated and trained
gary marcus saying things like oh look i
asked the agi if i asked hgb3 if a mouse
is bigger than elephant and it said yes
so obviously it's stupid but i think
this is like measuring a fish
fitness by its ability to decline what
you're articulating is that gbt3 is an
auto-aggressive language model
and all it's doing is predicting the
next word and
frankly it's incredible that it does as
well as it does because it seems to have
learned this
implicit knowledge base yes and even
though you've never told it what to do
so gbt3 at the moment
it's rubbish all it does is is produce
coherent text
it'll say that elephants can fit through
doors it's just completely stupid
it's not just better than gpt2 it is
remarkably better what scared me the
most in the gpt3 paper was this
straight line of perplexity
no i see it's a log plot but no sign of
slowing down
like no sign that there is ever an end
inside where we can just throw in
10 times more compute and 10 times more
data and we get out 10 times
better is that what the humans do all
they do is just
they take the generating function of the
real world
and then regurgitate that and one output
of that is language
right so that's how they produce the
language corpora but
all they do is basically just learn the
generating function of the universe
itself
we spoke about the great look up thought
experiment imagine you had
a agent who is composed of a lookup
table of
all possible states the universe could
be and an intelligent output to it
is this intelligent or not i think that
this is one of those
questions that is basically incoherent
because constructing such a table is
fundamentally impossible the commodore
of complexity
the length of the shortest program that
generates
that table might be small that's
important
it might be that there is a small
program
that can generate that table it can be
that the kamagara complexity of the
table is small
and then so then it's like the question
assuming i have
this short program assuming i have a
short program that can generate
this lookup table for any sub-sp i want
for any possible thing is that not
intelligent we spoke about newcomb's
paradox
some advanced decision problems and also
the concept of human rationality in
general
i feel a lot of the kahneman experiments
are just that we might not have the best
notion of utility function yet
i feel like this also this box example
doesn't that
kind of go almost into the nature of
whether or not we are a deterministic
machine i'm gonna make the argument that
newcomb's paradox is the default in
human interactions i think we all of us
encounter newcomers paradoxes
all the time in in one very simple
scenario
social interactions connor thinks that
ai alignment is very closely related
to economics i figured it out is that
economics is the same
problem as eyeliner alignment the
economy is a very smart optimizing agent
it can optimize very complex parameters
free market economy is many ways like a
kind of distributed back propagation
algorithm run on humans what should we
do if we're dealing with an artificial
superintelligence
which is significantly more intelligent
than us
how would it take over the world maybe
it'll invent this technology
but that technology seems unlikely
invented it could do this instead but
what if it does this instead
and that's doesn't get us anywhere i i
would like short circuit this
and say if you're dealing with an entity
that by definition is much more
intelligent than you
you should try to predict what it will
do formal decision theory is interesting
from the perspective of trying to
understand very powerful ais
we might be able to say things about how
these incredibly intelligent systems
operate even without us
ourselves being that intelligent spent a
lot of time today talking about the
dichotomy between utility functions and
intelligence
if it was an adversarial interaction
between me and an embodied ai
it doesn't really make sense to say this
ai wants to win what does that even mean
argument number one intelligence is
going to be very powerful argument
number two
instrumental conversions happens
argument number three defining correct
utility functions is very hard
argument number four by uh defining
human values is extremely high
it was very low entropy it's of all
possible value functions the value
functions that
capture human values are an extremely
small subset
we speak about some of the challenges in
decision theory and stability
and robust delegation so wireheading is
a problem
is that if a reinforcement learning
agent takes control of their own reward
signal why would they not just set it to
infinity and never do anything again
if we do build super intelligent systems
how can we ensure that the world will be
a better place as a result
i actually think that we should not want
a robot that will do
anything we say i would prefer that if i
told my robot
go murder innocent children the robot
says no i'm not going to do that
i want people to be happy i want
suffering to be minimized
by whatever means possible i do not give
a single
how we achieve a better world i
just care about us achieving a better
world
a mesa optimizer is an optimizer that's
found autonomously from a base optimizer
by searching over a space of possible
functions humans are a mace optimizer
for
evolution designed us looking for a
function that maximizes inclusive
fitness
but we optimize for completely different
things for like happiness and stupid
stuff like that
we are the ai that went out of control
as well as not making paper clips
instead of making babies
we're curing cancer and stuff like that
that is definitely not what the
what are what evolution intended we
speak about the concept of the stop
button
problem if we build a super intelligence
how could we turn it off
is it even possible to turn it off i
think the whole off button debate
because if we
end up building an ai like this there's
no way we shut off google
i believe that intelligence is
externalized and google
the corporation is a form of
externalized intelligence and
it's nebulous and diffuse and it's
self-healing if you attack
google they have teams of lawyers that
will respond to your attack
the concept of human rationality and
free will is ever present when you talk
about decision theory we also talk about
the dutch booking problem
there's a philosophical debate about
what is
rational what is the correct definition
of the world rational what
if you could modify your own rationality
the idea about dutch booking is that
assuming
you have someone who can offer you bets
that you can take a refuse
and that this person can reliably offer
you bets in such
a way that you will always lose money
and what about the relationship between
ai alignment and ai ethics
i have both very flattering and very
spicy things to say about ai ethics as
it currently is practiced
it's trying to put out your handkerchief
fire while your house is on fire
we also spend some time talking about
interpretability chris
olive has done more for machine learning
interpretability than any other person i
think in the last few years
he believes that it is possible to
understand
deep learning i once saw this great
graph like
the the y-axis is like interpretability
and the x-axis
is strength of the model and so it
starts really high like simple models
are really easy to understand
and then as it goes up like a little bit
the model is confused they can't really
make good concepts so it's hard to
understand
then it goes back up because the model
can make like crisp clean
definitely cut up you know concept in a
more meaningful way it's like where
humans and where our current ai systems
are
and then it plunges because eventually
it just becomes so intelligent it goes
so powerful
there's just no computationally
reducible way to understand what it's
supposed to do public figures such as
stephen hawking
elon musk and sam harris think that we
need to be super worried about
artificial general intelligence
they believe in the concept of an
intelligence explosion
or the singularity chalet and he's my
favorite person in the world
but he did write an article criticizing
the intelligence explosion
he says that intelligence is situational
there's no such thing as general
intelligence your brain is one piece in
a broader system which includes your
body
your environment other humans culture as
a whole no system exists
in a vacuum a very simple thought
experiment is that assume
i make an intelligence as smart as a
human just as smart as a single human
right
and now we just run it a million times
faster but this
assumes that virtualization of a mind
is even possible wittenstein's argument
about having a conversation with a lion
our intelligence how we perceive
intelligence is fundamentally linked to
not just biology but the systems we
interact with children that are raised
in the wild
they don't ever really come back we
don't currently see
anything that hints that there's
anything special about intelligence
i've tried something a bit different
today i've summarized a lot of the
core talking points into a 15-minute
introduction
and it might just be an interesting way
of getting a looking glass into some of
the topics that we covered today so
if you think that that's a cool way of
doing it then let me know
anyway remember to like comment and
subscribe i hope you enjoy the episode
and we'll see you back
next week hello hey connor how are you
doing man
hey yeah doing good doing good i just
exploded on a nature interviewer about
politics the other day
i've got to say though the missed
opportunity to turn that beard into some
weird spiky devilish thing yeah it's
it it is powerful like i cut this and
it just returns to the steak naturally i
don't get
hair anywhere else i don't get any kind
of beer it's just this
it is truly powerful that is the best
place to to have a beer though to be
fair
it kind of is yeah i gotta say i i got
like like on various like youtube videos
or like chats i've had with people i've
heard i've heard a pirate look i've
heard don quixote
i've heard i've got a few good nicknames
out of it
it's very jack sparrow it is like that's
that that's the like
0.5 percent portuguese genes
in may speaking unless i like part irish
portuguese and the portuguese gives me a
beard and i tan like
incredible in summer and the irish gives
me uh sailor's mouth
so amazing welcome back to the machine
learning street talk youtube channel
with me tim scarf my two compadres alex
basie and sten lake and yannick
lightspeed culture who'll be joining us
in a minute
and today we have an incredibly special
guest connor
leahy i've been watching several of
connor's talks online on youtube and
he's a really impressive guy actually i
think he's got a fantastic future ahead
of him
he's a walking encyclopedia of agi
and ai alignment knowledge so he's
interested
in artificial general intelligence
beyond deep learning
and even more so the alignment problem
in ai
so how do you build a friendly ai
what stops you is not that you don't
have enough computing power
even with infinite compute and memory
you just can't write the correct
python program which is going to lead to
a friendly ai
now connor founded luther ai which is a
grassroots ai research group
aimed at democratizing and open sourcing
ai research
in that group he's building new data
sets for language modelling
he's building a new gpt style model as
well and the largest model that they've
gotten to train for a single step so far
has been 100 billion parameters which is
pretty impressive they said on their
site that google reportedly got up to 50
utilization on their tpus when they
train similar models and they're making
a lot of progress towards that goal they
haven't quite got there yet
they're also interested in digital trust
for deep neural networks
so given query access to a model can you
determine whether the model was created
by
us in a way which is resilient to model
compressions that's super interesting
also can an organization that is
untrusted by the public
in some way prove that their models are
working as advertised and this might
lead us on to an interesting discussion
later
about the understandability of models
and one of the articles that's linked to
me
was by chris oller and interestingly he
believes that it's possible
to completely understand models albeit
if you turn it into a huge amount of
computer code connor's been a research
engineer at aleph alpha for just over a
year and he's finishing his computer
science degree at the technical
university of munich
he was an organizer at several data
science events the kaggle munich
and the pi data munich and connor
believes that
ai is the mass production of
intelligence
he believes that ai alignment is
philosophy with a deadline
and that we are on the precipice the
stakes are astronomical
ai is important and it will go wrong by
default
public figures such as stephen hawking
and
elon musk and sam harris they believe
that there's going to be an intelligence
explosion
and we need to be super worried about
artificial general intelligence
personally i i don't agree with them and
i think a lot of people in the machine
learning community are skeptical
but this is genuinely quite a divisive
issue which we're going to talk about
today
connor thinks that the singularity or
the intelligence explosion is very near
he also says that agi is a bit like
climate change
but worse even harder problems
even shorter deadlines and even worse
consequences for the future
so these problems are incredibly hard
and nobody really knows what to do about
them
connor it's an absolute pleasure to have
you on the show welcome
what an intro thank you so much for
having me
ai safety ai alignment debate it's
really interesting to see that there's
all these various
flavors and schools and approaches walk
us through like
why there are so many approaches to ai
safety and how they differ
do they differ in substance or is it
mainly in like how we actually implement
safe ai all right the field of ai
alignment has a little bit of a color
for history
so it's actually very interesting for
those people that are specifically
interested in a little bit of the
history and the anthropology
of this field i very much recommend the
book the ai doesn't hate you by tom
chivers if i remember correctly
it comes so some of the first people to
talk about ai alignment are a bit of a
unusual bunch of people so they came out
of these transhumanist
newsletters in the late 90s and early
2000s these are people such as eliezer
yudkovsky
and nick bostrom and several others
in many ways people i think it's fair to
consider that uh eliezer
koski is one of the great founders of
the field of course we have ij good and
other people that are much earlier even
still in the field yannick
who are even who appeared even earlier
talking about the concept of
intelligence explosions or whatever
but at least for me personally the way i
got into the field is from the writings
of jesus
who was a very early writer in this
field and he
was he was one of the first people to
kind of talk about many of these
concepts of how this will go back by
default
this is not an easy problem he events a
lot of the terms that we use nowadays
so there's this strand so eliezer koski
runs this organization he said miri the
machine intelligence research institute
that is the institute that he
leads or he's a lead researcher i don't
know exactly what his role is
but he founded it there are also
several other of these older
institutions such as the future of
humanity institute at oxford
and this has always been a very niche
subject this has been something you
couldn't
like study in necessarily publicly like
i remember
reading an interview with paul
christiana who is a
relative prolific ai alignment
researcher and he telling him about that
he had to have like a
a secret double life during his phds
that he wanted to work on the lie
alignment but he had to pretend he was
working on something different
and that has been changing so
due to the works of people such as max
tegmark
and nick bostrom and others steward
russell
there has been a lot of progress in
making ai alignment a more quote-unquote
respectable field something that more
people can work on full-time in their
phd
something you can get funding for
something you can publish about this is
a very recent development this is
something maybe it seems like 2018 i
would consider to be something that's
been
becoming something more mainstream
something that it's more okay to talk
about so it's actually surprising how
quickly things have changed
but this has also had to some degree
a a little bit of side effect that
some new approaches are some people new
to the field not necessarily know
the older approaches the field or the
older more let's say radical
views of the field the way i like to
think about this is that you can divide
the field into
several kinds of approaches of like how
hard do you think the problem is how
soon do you think the problem is going
to happen how dramatic of a of an uh
of a breakthrough do we need to solve
this on the one hand we have prosaic ai
alignment
this is stuff like paul christiana's
group at open ai student russell
chai and several others this is what i
would consider quote-unquote mainstream
um ai alignment research this is the
idea that
our future artificial super intelligence
are probably going to resemble our
current artificial intelligences they're
probably going to be neural networks
they're probably going to be you know
running on gpus they're probably going
to be using st you know creating descent
and therefore these people ask
themselves okay
given this how how can we align these
how can we
make a gbt model aligned what does it
mean to be aligned and such like this
what techniques can we do
this is what i consider probably the
most mainstream kind of current
uh alignment then there's the stuff so
it's ironic
is that miri was one of the very first
organizations to talk about alignment
and now they're considered something of
a black sheep
in the community is that miri is
legendarily hard to explain even what
they do
and no and like even people in the ali
alignment field are often
have different opinions about whether
what myriad is doing and makes sense or
not or is there
you know so to do my best to try to
say shortly what miri does is that they
say we are so confused
about what intelligence is about what
alignment means
about goals about optimism about all
these things
that we should sit down first and try to
figure out what these words even mean we
should
their idea is basically we are in the
pre-newtonian stage of intelligence
research
is that before newton invented his laws
of motion
we were able to build ships and
catapults and something happen trial and
error
and they could work pretty decently but
once we had newton's theories
we could make predictions we could
predict how to
how to make these certain things and it
was necessary to build very complex
machines you can't build
a rocket that gets you to the moon by
trial and error it could but
not really going to work in practice you
needed these predictive theories in
order to be able to aim for the moon you
needed to be able to predict how
gravity would behave in this scenario
that we have not yet seen
and miri is basically trying to develop
this for intelligence they're trying to
develop fundamental their understanding
of what is intelligence where
optimization processes
and how can we reason about like
decision theory how can we reason about
this
in a way that will apply to potentially
future
super intelligent systems could you
articulate what they believe
intelligence is i mean on this show
we've covered
francois chiles on the measure of
intelligence and last week we spoke to a
guy called walid sabo who's one of these
old school
expert system uh guys and he thinks that
intelligence is about explicitly
reasoning over
separate knowledge and doing the
statistical inferencing and so on
so what is the conception of
intelligence in your opinion
i take a very practical approach i say
intelligence is the ability to solve
problems
is you can get all philosophical about
it and you can get ready like that
mathematical about it
but i like for example that miri often
doesn't talk about intelligence they
often talk about optimization processes
and optimization pressure
so the the i could measure the power of
a system
by its ability to if introduced to a
system to
increase a certain value or decrease a
certain value
and but don't you think that skill
acquisition should be part of
intelligence
could be in in practice it would be you
know in every
practice kind of scenario it would be
there is the philosophy
like we could talk about definition of
intelligence that are like
philosophically
satisfying and we could talk about
deficiencies of intelligence that are
practically useful
and the fact that at the end of the day
if i have a system
that can take over the world economy can
cure aging cure
cancer build any kind of technology it's
at least for me it's not super important
how exactly this machine works
because i suppose one one way to
contrast this is that
in a way it's a cul-de-sac for us to get
bogged down in defining intelligence and
debating whether or not current systems
are intelligence because stuart russell
said
the primary concern is not spooky
emerging consciousness
but simply the ability to make high
quality decisions
and in that wonderful youtube video that
you linked to us which is i don't know
if i can pronounce his name you said
before
elysia zudovsky the ai alignment problem
and
he was basically saying it's really hard
and he started off by talking about
asimov's three laws of robotics which
were deontological
and for folks that are not educated in
philosophy that means that
rather than focusing on the outcome it's
just a kind of rules-based
system of ethics but his rules were a
robot
may not injure a human being or through
inaction
allow a human being to come to harm and
then the second rule was a robot must
obey
the orders given by human beings except
where such orders would conflict with
the first law
and the third one was a robot must
protect its own existence
as long as such protection does not
conflict with the first or second law
yes and that would not work practice as
that talk
explains in rather detail an interesting
point from that talk
was discussing the idea of utility
functions and how they're necessary to
get around the kind of
deontological traps that come out from
vaguely worded
first principles and it was really
interesting because they talk about the
importance of having a coherent
utility function and there are links
here to dutch book arguments in terms of
like probability theory
but on the show recently we've been
discussing a lot the problem
of setting objectives and targets and
the way that these can lead to perverse
examples
and in the talk the speaker quite
rightly identifies that humans
don't really have coherent utility
functions
not in any sense that we're aware of and
yet they seem to be a real central
principle for the the ai alignment
problem
is there a tension there or are we is
this just an
outsider looking in that that thinks
this is a bit of a conundrum
no absolutely can we give an example of
what we mean by humans don't have a
coherent utility function
it's pretty simple to get humans to say
for example they like pineapple pizza
better than salami pizza
and they like cheese pizza salami pizza
and they like pineapple pizza or the
cheese pizza
so it's pretty easy to get humans to say
statements like that
and if you think about it so i should
explain quickly what a dutch book is so
dutch book is actually a very important
concept in like these miri style
alignment research
so there's a very hard question to be
asked what is rationality
actually can i diverge for just a second
here i'd like to introduce a bit of a
a weird thought experiment i think it's
important to explain this this is called
newcomb this is called newcomb's paradox
and i think this is very important to
understanding some of the more advanced
decision theory
we might be talking about so douco's
paradox functions the following way
imagine a super aliened amiga comes down
from space
and so omega is arbitrarily intelligent
and that omega's arbitrarily intelligent
omega is a weird alien so it's playing a
weird little game it plays the following
game
it puts down two boxes in front of you
the first box always has a thousand
dollars in it
the second box has a million dollars in
it but
only if it predicted in its simulation
that you would only take the second box
so it puts down two bucks and it flies
away should you take
only the second box or both boxes
this is a interesting idea because the
boxes are already filled the million
dollars are already there or not
so whether or not you take it does not
change whether the million dollars are
already in the box
but you might argue that and i think
correctly argue so
i'm a one boxer that's what you call it
one box i would only take the second box
and because because then i would predict
because omega is super smart so omega
knows that i would have only taken
to the second box so i'll get a million
dollars but there are many kinds of
decision theories that's a lot
rationally you should be both boxes
because your choice will actually make a
difference at this point
so these are like different definitions
of rationality on the one hand you have
this like this like a causal rationality
or a causal decision theory
where you say my choosing of both boxes
will not causally
affect my output i will get a thousand
dollars more by picking both boxes
either way
if that's strictly dominant so i'll take
two boxes and then there is these like
more
abstract kind of like weird assistant
theory where he said
but i get more money by only picking one
boxes so i'll just pick it whether it
makes causal sense or not
and it's it's now a good time to
introduce daniel kahneman one
some was it the nobel prize for his he
showed that humans do not maximize
economic utility
so there was the experiment maybe you
can probably verbalize it better than me
but
people were more concerned about not
being
almost insulted by the other person yes
isn't this isn't this just a a
i feel a lot of the kahneman experiments
are just that we might not have the best
notion of utility function yet
given because we try to measure it in
money or something like this or like the
more pizza the better
but it i think a lot of condoms
experiments still make
sense if you assign the correct utility
function if you assign some negative
utility to risk
and to being embarrassed and and whatnot
whereas i feel that
a lot of these advanced decision
problems
they really require a different thinking
right like rather than we have this
monotonic utility function i also know
there's
there's this notion of i don't remember
it's a long time ago but like super
rationality where you're you you have
you're like pray play prisoners dilemma
but then you are think like okay the
other person is really smart
and i'm really smart and the other
person knows that i'm really smart and i
know that the other person is really
smart
and therefore if we're both so smart why
don't we just pick
both the same action like the cooperate
action
it makes to me this makes no sense like
at the point where you say
since we are so smart why don't we but i
i see like you can derive this
but yeah it makes no sense i feel like
this
also this box example doesn't that kind
of
go almost into the nature of whether or
not
we are a deterministic machine
because the whatever the omega
the super intelligence predicts what you
would do
if you're a deterministic machine then
your causal reasoning makes sense but if
you are not
then you should sample from a biased
coin
okay i have to pack some a few things
there you're completely correct and what
you're saying i completely agree is that
so like this concept that you could
so the thing with utility theory with
utility functions is utility functions
are an incredibly
huge space of possible functions you can
always find
some utility function that explains
someone's behavior
always it's just such a large space you
so that's why these concepts rationality
are very hard that's why i was going to
talk about dutch booking
is that if you see someone walk down the
street take out a gun and shoot
themselves
you're not you can't say that's
irrational because maybe their utility
function gave maximum utility for
shooting themselves and that was the
exact
best possible thing they could have done
it's hard to say or you might or
there's a second part of this so a a
agent is basically composed of two parts
you have the utility function of the
decision theory
is that it might just have a such a bad
decision theory such a bad rationality
actually shooting himself was a really
bad decision but he was so dumb that he
did it anyways because he was his
rationality was so bad
that he did that i know we are
accelerating towards the the freewill
debate
very quickly because the third thing is
maybe
the person didn't have any rationality
at all maybe
he was just acting randomly yes of
course
so there are so this is why i wanted to
so i'm going to get back to dutch
booking because dutch booking helps us
solve some of these problems
but basically uh okay like the super
rationality things well
let's talk about that later if you want
to talk about that later we talked about
it later but here's the thing with omega
so here's the thing with the newcomer's
paradox newcomb's paradox
in my opinion appears super strange like
it appears like this very bizarre
scenario that requires
really weird setups and blah blah blah
and for some of these
experiments that is true like i know
several style experiments that are
really funny but
honestly require like physically
possible things to happen for them to
occur
but i'm going to make the argument that
newcomb's paradox is the default in
human interactions i think we all of us
encounter newcomb's paradoxes all the
time
in one very simple scenario social
interactions
if i every time i'm talking to you i am
making predictions about what you will
predict i will do about what you will
predict i will behave how i will what is
socially acceptable
this is a newcomer a newcomb's game
and that if i whether or not for example
i decide to lie to someone
will depend on whether i expect them to
expect that i will lie to them or not
and just on that though isn't there a
kind of nash
equilibrium or a convergent behavior
that happens here because
it happens all the time that when we try
and derive we we
design objectives to nudge people to
behave the way we want them to
it might be kids at school we want them
to to do their exams and so on and
we try and and design objectives that
are so powerful
like for example if you can memorize a
long list of numbers
that's probably a good indicator if we
evaluate for it that you're good at
doing something else but
so many opportunities for perverse
incentives and shortcuts always manifest
yes absolutely it's okay
this is getting this is not exactly
about rationality at that point uh so
incentives
are important because basically
incentives help us shape
what actions lead to our highest utility
this is really interesting thing when i
first got into ai alignment research i
was really
i was confused that everyone was really
into economics
like every ai alignment researcher is
really into economics
and i didn't understand that at all but
eventually i found i figured it out is
that economics
is the same problem as alignment
economics is the question about aligning
incentives to
using dumb quote-unquote things
individual humans laws institutions to
control a smart thing
the economy is a very smart optimizing
agent it can optimize
very complex parameters in a very
right-wing scenario that individual
humans cannot do
in many ways the economy like our kind
of like free market economy in many ways
like a kind of distributed back
propagation
algorithm run on humans and in many ways
economics is about trying to align that
thing as close as possible to
things for example corporations have
figured out if they just dump their
toxic waste into some kind of like into
the amazon or whatever that'll make them
a lot of profit but that's a
misalignment that's not what we actually
want the economy to do so then we pass
laws that say okay it's illegal you have
to pay more money if you do that
and that is an attempt to align the
economic the economy
ai system optimizing system to our
values
post talk could i challenge
here then because adam smith said that
there was a hidden hand
in the market and do you think that the
market is a
i know charlay actually believes that
it's an externalized form of
intelligence
do you think the same i i think it's
again it's a i like to think about
optimizers more than i think about like
intelligence is a loaded word so i try
to think about optimizers here
is that the economy is optimizing for
certain parameters
and the question is are those parameters
we want or not so is there an invisible
hand
sure does the invisible hand give us
what we want that's not obvious to me
it is it will optimize for something and
the point for me of like regulation is
attempting to force the invisible hand
to optimize for something closer to what
we actually want
so coming back to social interactions
for a second
you made the point that this newcomers
paradox
is every day in social interactions is
there
but in isn't a big factor
in the social interaction that it's a
repeated game
so i am not going to lie to someone or
something like this because i interact
with them in the future
or i behave as they expect
because i'm going to interact with them
again
whereas in your case in newcomb's
paradox that
alien just flies away and
i i will never interact with them again
of course
that is a good point is that i'm not
every social attraction is only a
newcomb's paradox iterative prison
dilemma is probably the closer or a
stack hunt or probably the closer game
theoretical equivalence
to normal interactions but my point so i
got track there i'm sorry about that is
that what i
i was bringing up newcomb's paradox to
explain dutch booking and why it's
important for rationality
just for the benefit of the listeners
can you explain the prisoner's dilemma
that's the thing where the people can
dub each other in but they
yeah so the idea is you and your buddy
are
are can there's evidence that you may
have committed a crime but it's not
enough to convict you
so you're both put into a cell you can't
talk to each other and you have and the
police officer the following option
either you both
don't tell us and then we're going to
convict you for some minor crimes so you
go to your
to prison for one year or you rat on
your buddy
if he doesn't rat on you you go free and
he goes to jail for
six years or if you both rat on each
other you both go to years
to prison for four years so obviously
in some the best thing would be for both
people to interact
it's just to cooperate with each other
to not tell the police what happened
but for each one individually it is
better to rat
out the other person because if you
write me out i might as well write you
out and i'll save myself two years of
prison
if you didn't rep me out and i rat you
out i'm gonna save myself one year of
prison as well so it's always in my
interest
to write out the other person yeah and
this is spoken about a lot in
reinforcement learning especially
multi-agent reinforcement learning and
there are lots of efforts to
model intrinsic motivation i mean janet
can talk about this much better than
myself but you must see this quite a lot
that when you have individual agents
yes absolutely it's like the prisoner's
dilemma is one of the if i had to like
make a list of like top 10 things you
have to learn
period like just things that people
should be aware about prisoner's dilemma
teaches
so much about everything about how
people interact about how
governments interact about how decisions
are made it's
and the variance of the previous
dilemmas there's very much there's
variance the most important was the
iterative prison dilemma
assuming we don't play this once but we
played multiple times that might be good
to cooperate with you
so that we so we cooperate many times in
the future
this is also for example why the mafia
kills stitches is that they try to
say okay if you don't cooperate with us
we're gonna make it so bad for you
that it's not worth it so there this is
definitely something in real life and
it's in a fundamental thing about
understanding
like rational decision making on a semi
tangent if you go back to the
in the 1950s 1960s 1970s when this
stuff first got really big academically
around the same time uh
nuclear strategy was first emerging and
you get a lot of game theory in there
and there is some very dark but very
interesting reading i'm looking at the
applications of game theory to
the waging and prevention of nuclear war
it shapes a lot of how the world is
today
it's funny you say that because i was
going to invoke i know we said we won't
talk about politics and i promise this
will be a quick digression but i
am rand and of course she wrote this
book um atlas shrugged
and her writing influenced basically i
think there was even a rand corporation
and it influenced the
second half of the 20th century there
was this objective obsession
and most of the way that businesses are
run today is informed by that even as
you said things like
mutually assured destruction and the
randian philosophy is
present in a lot of places and it means
that if agents
only focus on their self-interest that
would actually maximize
um global utility i think if i'm stating
that correctly
what do you think about that are we sure
that iran is philosophy i'm pretty sure
it's pornography
it's called objectivism isn't it so it's
got a unofficial name so i
i have very i have i don't think much of
iron brand at all i think that
let me put it this way i think there are
better examples of what she was trying
to accomplish
so for example tara cohen's book suburb
attachments i think
is a much better case for the same type
of argument
he makes this case about how increasing
world gdp
is basically the most morally good thing
you can do and i think his case is much
stronger than anyone and rand ever did
so it's the following thing is that the
problem with like deontological and
and the problem i have like
deontological theories and like
non-utilitarian theories is that you can
always
construct a world state where
following those rules is bad you can
always find
some edge case which might be very edgy
or it might be
a very actually how the world works case
for example i like i i don't know if
you've ever heard of near reactionism
there is like monarchists they think we
should have a king and people slaves are
good and
it's hilarious it's terrible and the
thing is that
a lot of people take them strangely
seriously because their arguments
seem to make sense if you accept their
premises the problem is their premises
are just
wrong they're just not true it's just
they're just actually
for real made up they're just fantasy la
land stuff
and a lot of objectivism is similar is
that it seems to me is that she just
if you accept the premises of atlas
shrugged if you accept
all of this is how the world works this
is how humans actually behave this is
how actually
and yeah it's yeah it's good problem is
none of those things seem to be true in
the real world the real world does not
seem to follow these laws
and therefore it's uh very silly to in
my opinion to take them
too seriously it's uh morality is a
two-tier system it's not that you can
you can't just sit down and come up with
a true correct morality that will read
to the
best possible result without actually
observing the state the universe is in
and the rules the universe
follows just to throw a hand grenade
into the discussion
i was really fascinating like these
sorts of podcasts are a great way to get
into a new topic
that you don't often have a chance to
read and so i went out and started
reading some of these papers in
ai alignment research very heavy heavily
logical like
we're very used to looking at calculus
but like pure logic just
arguments made of pure logic as
something that you don't really
encounter outside of textbooks
but i kept wondering to myself if this
whole field is this construct of pure
logic
yeah sure our conclusions may be valid
given the premises but
what about the premises like i'm not
familiar enough with the entire debate
to go back and say this particular
premise is wrong
but we we seem to have all of the ai
alignment research seems to agree on
certain broad principles
things like the orthogonality thesis
things like instrumental convergence
but how much of this is someone said
this once now we all accept its gospel
because if you accept this
then it it naturally follows in a
logical state
sorry just one second so whenever we
have jargon i'm going to
intercept so the orthogonality thesis is
uh i think it came from bostrom
and he had this concept that utility
functions and
general intelligence can vary
independently of each other so
the idea is that we can have something
that's super intelligent
but will want to kill us or is dumb in
in the sense of what it's optimizing is
that fair
yeah basically okay and the other thing
you said
instrumental convergence there are
certain
sub-goals which are useful for a very
large range of final goals
for example almost doesn't matter what i
want to accomplish i need to be alive to
accomplish it in almost all cases
so most ais following most goals will
want to stay alive
this is nothing to do with like
consciousness or will to live or
emotions or anything it's just
if i want to get coffee if i just want
to get you coffee
i can't get you coffee if i'm dead so i
have to ensure that i stay alive long
enough to get you coffee
counter example a friend of mine was
training
a robot to walk set the time penalty too
high
and this robot would just tip itself
over and they couldn't figure out why it
was tipping itself over
before they figured out that the robot
had learned that the quickest way to
terminate an instance
and therefore minimize its regret was to
knock itself over
so in in such a situation like
this isn't to say that the theory's bunk
it's just to say that there are
real world counter examples that suggest
that instrumental convergence may not be
as powerful as
user input or initial conditions that's
not a counter example that's actually a
very classical example of the
stop button problem so there's this
unsolved problem basically is how do you
get an ai to willingly let you shut it
down that's actually very hard
is that if you don't give it any
incentive to let shut it down it will
resist being shut down
if you give it too much incentive to
shut itself down it'll shut itself down
and so it's so this is a very common
problem
now might be a good time just to quickly
touch on some of that stuff because in
that presentation by
alessia eliezer yakovsky thank you very
much
he started off by talking about we
started off with those asimov
deontological rules
and then he he framed that the alignment
problem is incredibly difficult because
if you have a
robot's utility function it's brittle it
might be something like this so we want
to fill a cauldron
with boiling water i think was the
thought experiment
and the utility function is one if it's
full and zero if it's empty the human's
utility function presumably
is is so much more complex it has a
fidelity that can't actually be
explicitly described
yes but here in in this case here's what
i'm always thinking when someone
comes up with this it's that i look at
this and i see two things i see someone
making these premise of we have this
super duper booper intelligent ai
right that is the unconstrained and
whatever utility function we give it
it can optimize and then we think of the
consequences
but then i look at the utility function
and i see
a 2000 and
year 2020 programmer that
programs a utility function as if it
were a reinforcement learning agent of
today
so it always pairs these mega
intelligent
ais with a utility function that is like
we would give an ai today because
it's easy states that map two single
numbers what if the utility function
is what like plus one if human dopamine
system
activated and then you'd be like okay
workshop flooded nah that's not good
dopamine low dopamine low funny
good dopamine high okay okay but yeah i
see what you're saying here about i like
i
so we've been building up technical debt
here in this conversation there's 10
things i
have to explain that we've just been
like adding on without explaining the
price this is our mission here
is is it a lifo stack yeah basically so
we have to
work off some of the technical debt here
okay so first of all i would like to be
very clear that every single thing that
has been brought up so far
is very well known in the alignment
sphere everyone talks about this
everyone is concerned with these
problems
you can find huge essays on the
alignment forum about every single one
of these topics
is a is there not something that like
you're right like i'm not saying
you're you're dumb or something i'm
saying yes you're very right they're
smart these are
good things that you're noticing it's
good that you're noticing these things
because these are serious problems
because my brain doesn't actually have a
you know stack that is in any way
consistent i don't remember everything i
have to work off my technical debt but
let me try to like look a little bit
backwards first
so i want to start with this idea so the
there is a failure mode in talking about
ai alignment which we are dangerously
close to
where it becomes an argument of my
sci-fi theory versus your sci-fi debunk
is that it can often come into like
these things i say ai could you take
over the world
and the other person says how would it
take over the world maybe it'll invent
this technology but
that technology seems unlikely invented
it could do this instead but what if it
does this
instead and that doesn't get us anywhere
i i would like short circuit this
instead say what most
advanced people in this field will try
to tell you is that if you're
is that just about from first principles
if you're dealing with an entity that by
definition is much more intelligent than
you
you should try to predict what it will
do you should just predict that it will
perform
better than you for example i can't
predict which move alphago will take
but i can predict that alphago will
probably win
and that is the only thing i am i think
we can say about very strong future
intelligence i can predict
that i can't predict how a future
intelligence might want to take over the
world but i can predict that it probably
will be able to do so if it if it's
utility function
wanted to do so now the quick challenge
on that
isn't that a little bit one-dimensional
in the sense that
go is a board game and what it means to
win
is clearly defined whereas if it was an
adversarial interaction between me and
an embodied ai
i don't think i it doesn't really make
sense to say this ai wants to win what
does that even mean
it's that's where we get into these
dutch booking and and utility function
things
that is we are still working from this
assumption that and or our intelligence
has some kind of utility function
and the reason this makes sense to a
certain degree is because utility
functions are universal
is that you have these like a von
neumann mortgage stand axioms where you
can basically say
even if no one sits down and writes a
utility function
you can describe an an agent fulfilling
these very
simple russiality priors as acting
as if it had a utility function that
means even so no programmer ever wrote
down a utility function it will
act as if it had a utility function this
is
this is why people use these theories
because it's very universal
there are problems with utility function
and one of the biggest open questions in
ali alignment is
can we find a better framing than
utility functions because utility
functions have a lot of problems that we
would like to get away from
but so far it's been very hard to find a
better formalism
than utility functions for thinking
about these very abstract very powerful
things so ai alignment and as safety and
air danger are based on
this like stack of arguments and this is
why i understand that sometimes these
arguments are hard for people to swallow
because often people will see one or two
of these arguments and then
and then they can easily dismiss them
you have to take the whole stack
you have to say you have to say okay
argument number one intelligence is
going to be very powerful
argument number two the instrumental
convergence happens argument number
three
defining correct function utility
functions is very hard
argument number four the by uh defining
human values is extremely high entropy
it's extremely high information it's
extremely hard or was very low entropy
it's of all possible value functions the
value functions that
capture human values are an extremely
small subset
so we should expect that by default
unless we have enough
you know knowledge to hit this very
small target in optimization
space that we will hit something wildly
different and that we should expect that
this wildly different thing will do
something
that we might not be able to predict but
that will we could predict will not be
something that we necessarily want
and so it is this like weird stack of
arguments that all interact with each
other and if you
take out one of them then the conclusion
doesn't really hold anymore or it's not
as strong
and you can just quickly another
question so because you said the space
of human utility functions is
almost infinitesimally small compared to
the space of utility functions
but if you were to take a convex hole
over all of the different individual
human utility functions would it look
quite clustered in that space
or would it be uniformly distributed
this really depends on what space we're
talking about here the space of all
functions because a utility function in
any computable function and that is a
large space yeah it is i suppose what
i'm saying is that presumably they're
more
my utility function and yannick's
utility function presumably they're
significantly more similar to each other
than
any other uh utility function picked at
random from that
space yeah i'm trying to reason about
what we're looking for here
robert miles said something on this a
couple of years back
talking about the nature of intelligence
and he says okay think about all the
kinds of human intelligence they're an
area of this big
there's the camera they're an area this
big and if we think about all the
potential
intelligences of living things on earth
it's like this big
and if we think about any potential
biological intelligence it's like this
big
but that's still not the entire space of
intelligence it's huge and we don't even
know
what it looks like utility functions are
exactly the same yes if we're talking
about human
human intelligence it makes sense to
reason about like convex hulls
within this like subspace because even
if we're wrong we're only going to be a
little bit wrong
but if we're talking about something
that's non-human and
acts in a way that could be construed as
intelligent
then the question becomes a lot more
complex
just quickly the utility function
presumably changes all the time it's not
static
or do you think it has a level of
dynamism so that
you could think of it as being static
but it changes static
right you can probably formulate and
take a time parameter in or whatnot
but here is a thing and then i also want
to backtrack the stack but
here is a thing that i'm very sure the
first person confronted with this
came up with but the answer might be
interesting
presumably we're going to build this
super intelligent
whatnot and it's going to be intelligent
and on the way there it might be
intelligent enough that we still can
make control what if we use that
to build us the utility function that
is aligned with us yeah so
what i can say is for sure it's
intelligent and therefore it's probably
going to come up with
the best utility function this is for
very strong definition of the world best
and
intelligent and whatever but actually in
many fields of er and many
people in alameda actually do think
versions of this they actually do
believe i believe a version of this is
that in a way
we have to build yeah we have to use the
intelligence of stronger agents to make
them align themselves
in many ways this is for example the
idea behind what's called courage
ability
the idea is to build an agent that
always
wishes to be more aligned so even if it
starts out unaligned
it will use its own intelligence to try
to make itself more aligned
like this is one of the uh more popular
approaches towards actual alignment
that doesn't what yannick said it links
back to the orthogonality thesis because
why wouldn't
a really intelligent agent change its
utility function
given it's super intelligent okay now
we're going to get into some deep
decision theory so there is
making decision theories robust under
this kind of things is
an open mathematical problem so like for
example imagine i
offer you a pill if you take this pill
you're gonna want to kill your entire
family and you're gonna be super
happy about it all the time should would
you take the pill or not
from a pure utilitarian perspective
whether you take it or not doesn't
really matter if you don't take it
you're happy that you didn't kill your
family if you take and you kill your
family you're super happy that you kill
your family
so in a way from a pure like dumb
decision theoretical perspective
these actions are have the same utility
and it doesn't matter which one you pick
but from our perspective like that
doesn't seem correct like
there's something wrong here like that
we should have a decision theory that
robustly does not take the pill
this is especially becomes a problem
with what's called wire hitting so wire
heading is the problem
is that if a reinforcement learning
agent takes control of their own reward
signal
why would they not just set it to
infinity and never do anything again
and so this can it does happen
and it's extremely non-obvious to me
as a lot of people think about this how
to solve this problem or if this is a
solvable problem i've heard people
propose solutions to it or
ideas about how to address or whatever
but this is a it's a very thorny issue
it's i think what you've described there
is gandhi's stability argument
and i was going to ask you what does
stability mean but i think you've just
answered the question but
there's a kind of convergent behavior in
many of these
decision frameworks and sometimes they
don't converge
the gandhi example was he starts out not
wanting to murder people
and then we offer him a pill that will
make him murder people but he knows what
the pill does so he says no sorry guys
i'm not having that pill because i don't
want to murder people
yeah this is also this so this is in
many ways robust
what's called robust delegation is which
is a
sub part of the alignment problem it's
the question how
is that not just so there's different
parts delegation
there's we delegate to an ai there's ai
delegates to a copy of itself there's
a.i
delegates to a new ai the ai delegates
to an improved version of itself
and also like delegates to a future
version of itself in many ways i know if
you guys ever done this before but
sometimes i will not
buy sweets at the supermarket because i
know i'm going to eat them if i'm at
home
in many ways this is an alignment
failure i have i am i am not aligned
with my future self
my previous self so i like have to
create like these artificial scenarios
to stop future cell from doing something
that i don't want him to do
you even see this in practice when they
hook up rats to
electrodes that can just stimulate their
brain they'll just push them
indefinitely so at some point we might i
think the
one of the more and that would be
what you mentioned at the very beginning
where you say ai
in the near future is probably going to
look like we engineer neural networks we
optimize with back propagation
that might just be solved with
engineering constraints like
we just screw over the ai's attempt to
do that by itself but it's
yeah it's an interesting problem it
refers back to what we have on the stack
a bit which is this
this stop button issue isn't that kind
of a version of the same thing so what
can you tell us a bit more about the
stop button problem
and how that plays into this yeah a very
common
thing that people will say it will
suggest when they first hear about ah
great you've got it here is that well if
the ai does anything better we'll just
shut it off
i think this is a very silly idea for
motivation so
here's a great example that uh tim has
got here from the talk where
let's say we have these utility funds
for the robot we give one point if the
cauldron is full and the turn off button
is off
and but we also give him the button we
also give him
one reward if he suspends himself after
you press the button
so what will this robot do let's
immediately hit the button
because filling the cauldron is hard but
suspending is easy so just hit the
button and go unconscious and then get
one reward so
success and it's very hard to find a
mathematically rigorous way of how to
define
an off button in a way where an agent
will actually
honor our our wishes in a good way and
okay
so here's i'm gonna i'm gonna take a
step away from like moderate from like
main street i research and talk about my
own beliefs a little bit
is that i actually think that's not
something we want i
actually think that we should not want a
robot that will do anything we say
because i think humans a lot of very bad
things and i think if we have a
robot that will do not they will not do
a very bad thing
that is preferable i would prefer that
if i told my robot
go murder innocent children the robot
says no i'm not going to do that
but that is not but that
goes against this kind of like alignment
with following human
wishes directly and doesn't that lead
very quickly to a trolley problem
yes would you would you make the same
argument about
let's say guns if i could build a gun
that whenever you point it at a child
which is not fire
it's more complicated than that it's
because so first of all it depends if
the gun is sentient or not or is has an
intelligent or an optimization is your
gun
optimizing for damage i'm a very
practical
utilitarian let me be very clear about
this i want
people to be happy i want suffering to
be minimized by whatever means possible
i do not give a single how we
achieve a better world
i just care about us achieving a better
world if having guns
around makes the world a better place i
want us to have guns
if having not having guns around makes
us a better world i want to not have
guns laying around
it's a very practical in that sense what
about
and another because we've got kenneth
stanley coming on the show and he has
this wonderful book called greatness
can't be planned talking all about
at the at the worship of objectives
being a tyranny
but one interesting concept i've already
taken from his book is that he says that
we
when we optimize objectives we're
looking for this monotonic increase in
utility and actually a lot of times
things have to go
significantly worse before they get
better for example
if we took away guns suddenly you might
find that led to
some unexpected outcome but in 10 or 15
years it might provide a better society
for us
so we need to prepare ourselves to take
that dip before it gets better later
yeah absolutely this is just the
difficulty of the space we're searching
through
if is that the the space of actions we
can take and their output
in the form of world states that we can
take if we try to formalize this somehow
not really
is that there's a fundamental question
of like how much structure
is in this space we have no free lunch
in that in a truly random
space you can never do better than
random search you know there's no
possible way
but we all assume and are living proof
that there is structure to our universe
there are regularities that we can
exploit to produce better than random
outputs
it's not always monotonic it's not
always perfect we get stuck on
local optimum minima and whatever but
all of these are basically
properties of the space and properties
of the space of the search algorithm
we're using to surf through them
intelligence is a search algorithm in
this space of policies in the space of
choices that it can it can effect of
parameters it can influence
in order to achieve better a world stage
which are rated higher on its utility
functions
in the most maximally abstract way to
define this it's quite interesting
you're talking about intelligence as an
output i think chalet says that it's
actually a
a process of information acquisition
but it's it's really interesting that a
lot of people do formalize it in the way
that you do which is that it's a search
problem looking for a program
yeah i don't want to any definition of
intelligence i genuinely do not want to
commit into any one definition of
intelligence
i think there are many different
definitions of intelligence that are
useful in different contexts
i like i find like the search of policy
or this like meta-learning definition
makes sense in this context there's
other contexts where others might
be more sensible but i i think this is
again i try to like sometimes when we
get like really into these abstract
things i try to like to ground things
again is that again
i don't care about how it works i don't
care what it is i care about making the
world a better place i care about making
people happy i care about avoiding
suffering i care about hearing cancer
and everything else is just my tool and
the tool set to achieve those goals
and yeah in a weird way you are
exactly like the problematic instances
of
agi we describe where they don't care
how many peop like how they construct
paper clips
as long as any means
in a way you act exactly like this which
is interesting
actually yeah actually we're just making
sure that we have a pathological example
to study
exactly no but that's actually really
funny there's actually a great story to
be told here about a mesa optimization
so one of the one of the things that the
airline research has like been talking
about a lot of recently which hasn't
really filtered the mainstream this
concept of mesa optimization
the idea is assuming you are you're
learning you're
searching for a a policy to optimize a
certain thing
it might be that the program that you
find is itself an
optimizer for something else and this is
amazing optimization and humans are a
mace optimizer for evolution
designed us looking for a function that
maximizes inclusive fitness but we
optimize for completely different things
for like happiness and stupid stuff like
that the
evolution doesn't care at all we are
misaligned ai
this is why this is one of the reasons
why i think that it is so
obvious that ai is going to go live
because we are misaligned ai
we are the ai that went out of control
as well as not making paper clips
instead of making babies
we're curing cancer and stuff like that
that is definitely not what the
what are what evolution intended now
might be a good time to talk about
inner versus outer alignment by the way
so i want to introduce this concept
the inner alignment problem is about
aligning the model with the loss
function the thing you're training for
so we'll know about this in
in machine learning so the reward
function outer alignment is aligning
that reward function that loss function
with the programmers intentions
ensuring that you write down a loss your
model is going to actually optimize for
this now i'm sure everyone has seen this
but there's this wonderful
there's this wonderful open ai page
talking about faulty reward functions in
the wild
and in the reinforcement learning world
we talk a lot about reward shaping
which is this thing we were just saying
that when you have objectives
intelligence systems will take shortcuts
and they'll just do whatever they need
to do
to maximize that objective and they
don't even care about the thing that you
actually want them to do
so this is an example of a game called
coast runners where the boat is going
round and round in circles
and it's just picking up points from
these little gems
in the water and it's not even
completing the the lap the way it's
supposed to be
yep absolutely and this is a very big
problem and this is a
in many ways yeah i love the framing of
inner versus outer alignment i wish
i hope that it becomes more mainstream i
think it's a great framing
is that so audio alignment is what we've
all talked about what is the correct
utility function how do we find a
utility function as good
inner alignment is a space optimized
question so if we run set the stochastic
rated descent on our loss function
does it actually even optimize it or
will it find just something that looks
like it's optimizing it but actually
optimizes something different
yeah i wanted to say something about the
stop button problem to
to back i'm trying to constantly
backtrack a bit to also clean up the
technical depth is that
if you look in the practical world if i
think of
of ai and really good ai and
i think most people think of something
like a little computer that goes
and we input and and maybe that has an
off button but if i think of
ai i think of something like google
right like
the search engine mail ecosystem that
we've built up
and that might have an off button
or like 20 but we can't like we simply
can't i think
the whole off button debate because if
we end up building an ai like this
there's no way we shut off google the
world goes down if we
shut off maybe not okay maybe at this
stage we can still shut off google
and we could survive but it's it's going
to be horrible and if we build something
more intelligent that's going to be more
useful to us
and i think i don't think that the stop
button debate
as you said it makes sense and it's not
something
we first it's not something we want but
second it's not something that we
even now can conceivably do i agree with
what yannick said
because i believe that intelligence is
externalized and google
the corporation is a form of
externalized intelligence and
it's nebulous and diffuse and it's
self-healing if you attack
google they have teams of lawyers that
will respond to your attack
if you take down their servers their um
scripts will
fix the server and put it online again
it's already
a kind of living breathing system that
you can't possibly stop
the crop of death yeah like there's a
great little essay called what failure
looks like by paul cristiano which i
find very interesting
so as i've mentioned like the early ai
alignment was much about intelligence
explosions and super intelligence
liquefying the plan with nanobots and
stuff like that there's a lot of sci-fi
stuff in there
and paul cristiano deserves a lot of
credit for being one of the people that
creates much more down-to-earth type
scenarios and
what he basically describes scenario
like how ai alignment could go wrong
without any catastrophe
this idea is just everyone every step of
the way
people just do a little bit more to the
ai living a little bit more decisions
let it take control of a few more
corporations deploy a
few more recommender algorithms bit by
bit and bit by bit humans just lose
all connection to reality we just read
and see whatever you want
the economy is run completely by
algorithms just step by step at no
point in time just bit by a bit all
human corporations
are out competed by alignment things and
at some point
that's it just humans have no more
influence no one ever
did anything there was no war there was
no fight it was just at some point we're
just all
sitting around and have no more
influence on our future whatsoever so
okay back to dutch booking
yeah that's where we interview that's
where we interrupted
something that you wanted to get yeah
that was like an hour ago
yeah all right dutch booking so this is
again like a whole artist this is backed
about rationality
so it's very hard to define what a
rational what is rational as i say
when you have a newcomers paradox it's
there's an argument to be made that
taking both boxes is rational that's
what we call this causal
decision theory that there's an argument
to be made there but there's other
decision theories that would say it's
not rational to do that
so there's a debate about a
philosophical debate about
what is rational what is the correct
definition of the world rational
what if you could modify your own
rationality
what should you modify it to be and
this is its philosophy so there's a lot
of debate here of course but what i
personally find is the most satisfying
answer i found so far is basically to be
immune to dutch booking the idea about
dutch booking is that assuming
you have someone who can offer you bets
that you can take a refuse
and that this person can reliably offer
you bets in such a way
that you will always lose money and this
is also similar to the idea of if you
like pineapple more than salami and you
like smiling more than cheese and you
like salami
you know cheese more than pineapple i
can make a lot of money by
charging you one cent to cha exchange
your piece of pizza over and over again
and this is also going to money back
this is the circular reference
thing right yeah like for example yeah
if you want to be in the one country in
one city more than the other city
in the other city in the other city and
you're willing to pay money to move from
one to the other you'll pay infinite
money going in circles all the time
and the theory is that if you had a good
rationality this should not happen
because it should be forbidden from this
kind of stuff time and the more
general class of dutch book or money
pump attacks should be impossible
you should find your theory it should be
impossible to extract
unlimited amount of your resources
without for no reason
but could i gently challenge on that
because it seems like that would be an
inconsistent utility function if that
existed but
if it was an ai agent that would just as
you say it would spend infinite amounts
of money on uber
and it would always be moving but if it
was me maybe i would move around a few
times and then i would
my system two would kick in and i'd
think hang on this is stupid i'm going
around in circles here
i'm just gonna stay in berkeley for a
while this is what yank was saying
earlier about
if you want to model this just put a
dependency on t
the parameters depend on t and then
you're good yeah yeah
this is is it possible though is it
possible
to have an inconsistent utility function
what's wrong with that
so it's not just on utility functions
it's also about rationality so there are
certain ways
okay so this is i couldn't do this
without a whiteboard in our time to
rehearse it exactly
if you update your beliefs and things in
a beijing way that is a very horror a
very computationally hard so if you like
a bayesian theorem to update your
beliefs which is the correct way to do
it
you is like almost attractable and you
could show
that if agents for example do not do
this bayesian but they do it in like
certain like approximate ways that are
biased
you can offer them bets about their
beliefs
and then like present them information
and offer them new bets
in a circular way that you that by
because they're not
updating completely because they're
updating incorrectly the the beliefs
they have
are biased in a way that allows you to
extract infinite money from them
and so benchmarking is a large category
the circular preferences is just a
funny example but it is a much wider
theory
of finding flaws in the way decisions
are made
in order to extract money from them so
like in many ways you can like frank
there's like versions you can frame
newcomers paradox
in different ways to extract money from
people that don't
that don't one box there's ways to so
it's could i challenge that as well
because we talked about the social
dilemma and then there's a free will
there's an addiction debate there
do people really want to be watching
this crappy content on facebook
do people really want to be gambling and
it's so paternalistic for us to say that
i don't think that's good for people
because i think part of human
flourishing is doing stupid stuff
if we had a consistent utility function
we would be so boring
all right i'd like to separate two
topics i'd like to separate the topic of
decision theory which is a purely
mathematical topic that's what i'm
talking about right now
this has nothing to do with philosophy
nothing to do with humans nothing to do
with the real world
the purely mathematical uh question of
is there a uni are there uniquely
better rationalities now the rationale
is a purely mathematical question the
reason i said that is you said i'm
as a human if i could choose my own
reward or utility function
then i would choose one which was
consistent so i think
you were making that statement okay you
know that's fair it's fair
but the the next thing i'm going to say
is again your decision theory is not
your utility function your decision
theory is what you use to optimize your
utility function
so if your utility function includes
sitting around all day and eating potato
chips
then having the best decision theory
cannot be worse
having a better decision theory will
only improve your ability to sit around
all day
and eat potato chips on the couch all
day so it's important to separate your
decision theory from your utility
function
what you just described would you just
ask about what if you would actually
want
this as a philosophical argument about
first and second order preferences
so there is this idea of like first
order preferences i want to do x
and then there's a second order
preference of like i want to do x
i think this is a super fascinating
important topic that i'd like to talk
about
but it is a separate topic from the
decision theory
okay are there any other scenarios where
humans could go around in loops like
this
imagine that you had you damaged your
memory
and so you just kept making the same
mistakes in life again and again
you kept you got into self-destructive
spirals of behavior that was deleterious
to your well-being
so humans do stuff like that all the
time gambling addiction drug addiction
romantic love i don't know if you've
ever happened to you sure as to me
unfortunately yes but i think those are
like separate those aren't
because our decision theory is bad those
are just because humans are flawed in
many ways
there's many other ways in which we're
flooded before we even get to a formal
decision theory so i think formal
decision theory is interesting
from the perspective of trying to
understand very powerful ais
there's this question of if i give you a
very large
system a very large program
what can you tell me about this program
and it's provable that in the limit you
can tell me nothing says rice's theorem
is that if you give me an arbitrary
turing machine i can't
prove any non-trivial statements about
this machine
but this is but we can construct a
subsystem or certain
classes of systems that we can predict
that's how our computers work is that we
construct our computers to abstract away
quantum noise
so we can better predict how they will
behave in the real world so we can
behave
treat them better this is also what i
meant about alphago that i can't predict
which move alphago will take but i can
predict that it is very likely to win
again
so there's a statement i can make about
a stronger more intelligent entity
so the the reason i'm interested in
decision theory is that if there is
a verily one or a class of
our most powerful decision theories then
we can predict that a most powerful
intelligence will use those decision
theories
and if we can then derive any knowledge
from how those
decision theories work we might be able
to say things about how
these incredibly intelligent systems
operate even without us ourselves being
that intelligent that's why i'm
interested in that but you said there'd
be a massive asymmetry so we wouldn't be
able to make many assertions at all if
we are the lower intelligence
potential yes so like in the limit it's
like if you have a program with a
certain amount of resources
okay now we're getting into complexity
theory that's one of my favorite topics
there is like this concept of kolmogorov
complexity which is this idea of the
minimum possible length of program that
gives you a certain output
and this is a very fascinating concept a
very useful concept in thinking about
programs
and i find it's fascinating that this is
a thing that
exists it's imputable because you have
to solve the halting problem to find it
but it is a thing that exists
and this okay jesus fight guys wait hold
up on a second i have to like
not start talking about pseudorandom
numbers but
basically if we have an algorithm has a
certain minimum length like it needs at
least these many steps to perform the
algorithm
then but we only have a smaller number
of computational steps we are allowed to
perform
then we can always only approximate the
solution of the actual problem
or guess at it but that's the same as
approximating so in the same way
because let's if an agent is irreducibly
complex to a certain degree like i
i would expect that i would expect that
i
can that the end the compute i would
need
to make as good decisions alpha go in a
go game
are on the same order of magnitude as
the decision of the
computation that alphago actually
performs and there's no way for me to
perform one step of calculation and
immediately know what alphago is going
to do next that's just a fundamental
property of how the algorithm works is a
fundamental mathematical property
of this algorithm there's a the
kamalgarh complexity is
has a certain size and if i don't have
at least enough compute to run this
algorithm
i can't i can only make approximate
predictions about it
there's also a compute and storage
trade-off so you could argue that
alphago has
memorized basically a whole bunch of
different moves sure so i still need end
steps to read and memory and
gpt i want to bring that up very briefly
because we're talking about memorizing
moves
now you feel gpt 3 is a great wake-up
call
for society in general as a warning
about
the potential of ai and as well as its
its impact on the internet information
space
now that's a valid argument you've
presented in other talks about how
gbt3 does amazing things you can
literally feed it information and it's
almost like talking to a person
yannick and i believe tim as well have
taken quite a look at gpt
3 and what it's actually learning
whether or not it's just learning a hash
function a search function
whether or not it's just memorizing
things and with so many parameters
how do you answer that charge when there
is good evidence that gbt3 is memorizing
are we actually talking about
intelligence here are we talking about
smart searches and if it's
not intelligence then should we actually
be that worried
all right question a kind of question
are humans intelligent
occasionally are you sure they just
memorize a lot of have you ever
talked to a school kid after
they you know wrote an essay they have
no concept of one within the essay
they're just regurgitating things
the teachers said there's no
understanding there's no
delay i've corrected the college level
essays before as a ta job
and stuff they have no idea it's just
regurgitation it's just babbling there
is there's no underlying
theory or anything i don't think humans
are intelligent i think it's an open
problem whether humans are intelligent
or not
that is that is that's an extremely
valid point and that's why yes
the specific argument that i made at
least wasn't that
gpt3 isn't intelligent but that gpt-3
isn't doing whatever you might call
reasoning
which is if humans do something they do
memorize
certainly a lot but they also appear to
do
something like manipulate logical
symbols in their head in a stepwise
fashion
which we might call something like
reasoning like if this then that and so
on
which i can't see any evidence that
something like gpt3 does
so far yeah this is one of the main
problems in intelligence
because as you pointed out even in
humans you can teach kids
how to do their times tables and what
the rules are for multiplication
and they can use their system too but
after a while
they will just memorize the results and
they'll shortcut and this
this problem of imitation is pervasive
and neural networks are interesting
because if you look at alphago i said
earlier almost
taking the piss a little bit that it's
memorized all of the
moves but of course it hasn't because
there are an incredibly high number of
possible moves what it's actually done
is it's through self-play it's generated
a whole bunch of data
and then it's created this hierarchical
entangled representation of all of these
different board positions and then
inside that convex hull of possible
positions it's cleverly interpolating
between them
that's exactly what gpt does but as
janik said what
we humans do is we have this ability to
abstract and go one level up and to
reason
and to distill our own knowledge it's
definitely not doing that
all right i like i'd like to say three
different things the first thing is i
wanna layout just for the sake of
getting the things heated i wanna say if
i completely subjective things without
any
backing i would just say some something
i believe and i'm not going to back it
up
i'm going to get back to it later and
obviously that's
your proactive on purpose then i'm going
to
say how i perceive my brain actually
working
and why i think that how i that how most
people describe their brain working is
at least not my experience at all
and then i want to make the case that
then i'm going to get back to then i'm
going to make a case about uncertainty
and
computation about how we don't actually
know how this is working okay
i'm going to start with the first thing
i think gb3 is artificial intellige
i think gpt3 is as intelligent as human
and
i think that actually is probably more
intelligent in the human in a restricted
way
in a very specific way let me
finish a little uh i'm going to back
this up i'm going to stop don't worry
and i also believe that in many ways
uh it is more purely intelligent than
humans are
i think that humans are approximating
what gpt3 is doing not all vice versa
and that's that's that yeah this is
going to be uh
it's a yeah it's a little controversial
let me try to explain this i've written
this great essay
recently called babylon fruit which kind
of explained a little bit about how
they perceive their brain to work and
this is very similar to how i
think so when i sit down to write a
talk so i have to give a talk the way i
do it is that i first generate a bunch
of really bad talks i start i just
started talking i just opened my mouth
and just start speaking
and a lot of things come out and i'll
start saying hey everybody i am uh
no wait i should open this differently
and then i go back and then i
regurgitate another sound and then
eventually i find something that i like
and then i keep that and then i start
regurgitating more things and then i
pick and prune
there's a lot of things that i see to
showing that humans are
do things like that like humans the
neocortex seems to do kind of like
generative modeling of some kind
whatever
and so there is very weak evidence that
gp3 may or may not be doing something
like that
but i want to make a much stronger claim
here so the third thing i want to talk
about is that
from an algorithmic perspective from the
purely
abstract theoretical computational
perspective
it is defining what is the same
algorithm
what is the same computation what
properties computations have
are undefined questions are our
questions that require solving the
halting problem
in that regard it is a we don't know
what gpt-3 does we do not know and
anyone that says they does
is lying because they can't know what
gp3 is actually doing because
that question is undefined as an
undefined answer and we don't know what
humans do
we we know some things about what is
going on but
the the magic of touring universality
means that
even a very modestly powerful algorithm
can approximate
any other possible algorithm so if we
look at the brain
there doesn't actually seem to be any
module for like logical reasoning for
like symbol manipulation whatever and
this is actually something that humans
are very bad at
people have to be taught this they have
to practice this this is not something
they do automatically
so in many ways it looks like we are
using a completely different mechanism
to approximate a simple manipulation
algorithm
which is not that surprising so i i'm
going to talk about it in a second after
you guys can all
yell at me uh about why i about uh you
know i talk about why i think gv3 is so
intelligent
but i would like to make a a statement
of uncertainty here is that
i said this obviously for the memes but
at the heart
i think that
the even asking is this algorithm
intelligent is a question that doesn't
really make
sense from a computational perspective
the question is far more
does it produce intelligent behavior
does it produce
a behavior with a reasonable
time complexity there is this concept in
computational complexity theory of
different levels of complexities and if
you get into these exponential
complexities even very small problems
quickly become
impossible to compute and to me
if i had an algorithm that had like an
np oracle so it could just
evaluate every possible timeline
simultaneously in one time step
it would be more intelligent than any
other system ever it by definition
it would by definition always choose the
correct choice
it would never be wrong but then you
could ask the question
but is it really intelligent because
it's actually just evaluating all
possible timelines
so there is a definition of intelligence
of compression there's this idea that
intelligence
is the compression the exploitation of
structure
in the structure of the space of the
search function
is that a more intelligent system can
reach a
better approximation of the correct
answer in a smaller polynomial amount of
steps
and if you define it that way then i can
see that there might be a definition of
intelligence in an algorithmic sense
that could make sense
but if that is the definition you're
looking for then we can't talk about
gbt3 in that regard because
we just don't have we don't know what
the true entropy
of language is we don't know what the
true difficulty of the search problem is
and so i i think that there's no way to
really answer that question
but i think we're playing fast and loose
with the definition of intelligence here
because
compression and machine learning are
very closely related
i can buy that especially coming back to
our notion of corn grove complexity
earlier but
no one really thinks that machine
learning algorithms are intelligent not
seriously
i do i think this brings us on just
quickly to the scaling hypothesis
because i think this is a nice segue we
all know gawan
he said that this the strong scaling
hypothesis is that once we find a
scalable architecture like
self-attention or convolutions
which like the brain can be applied
fairly uniformly
we can simply train ever larger neural
networks and ever more sophisticated
behavior will emerge naturally as the
easiest way to optimize for all the
tasks and data
he really thinks that if we just scale
these things up we're going to get onto
the intelligence explosion a little
while but there's this
the singularity is near by ray kurzweil
and he really described this concept
that as we exponentially increase our
technology and computing and genetics
and so on that
we'll almost have this runaway breakaway
effect where we'll just lose control and
the thing will just get better and
better yes but and you believe that's
happening with gpt3
yes so a little bit of backstory perhaps
so i thought deep learning was dead in
2017.
i was convinced in 2017 that the bubble
has burst deep learning is
dead like why do we even research it
there's nothing more to have here
we had all these scans yeah wow
what did they do to offend you
no no like i get it i'm just trying to
explain my own a little bit of
intellectual journey here
so i was super unconvinced that dublin
was getting where it was such a simple
method
are you kidding me matrix
multiplications wow intelligence boys we
did it
it's you know it seemed so preposterous
that there's ever and i looked at the
brain and had all this complexity
because i came from neuroscience or
actually
one of my first love was neuroscience i
i loved neuroscience and i saw this
complex things the brain does it's so
clever and
it's like mystical feeling of obviously
the brain must be doing something so
much more
intelligent and much more clever and
whatever and from that moment i gave a
talk like 2017
in the local meetup about how deep
bloody is dead and that
day cursed me that was from that day
forward i was cursed
that every single day everybody in the
entire world will work to show me wrong
so so everything
so i was again and again every time i
said oh deep learning cannot do x a
paper that would do that would come out
the next day it was like a magical power
and yeah and then there's a chorus of
people that say oh that's not really
intelligence
yeah one step yeah so this happened to
me
over and over and over again and what is
the definition of intelligence doing the
same thing over and over again and
respecting a different result so at some
point i was like okay you know what
maybe i was wrong
maybe i was goddamn wrong so the height
of this
was last year with gpt2 gbt2 came out
and there's a lot of hype that people
like oh this might be intelligence
whatever
and i was like nah look they just made
this thing bigger and look it's
cute but it's not that big of a deal and
i would have bet i would have bet any
money
on it like nope this is it they okay
they made their big stupid model
this is the end look it's it makes
slightly funnier sentences but that's
this is the limit but but just on that
let's say you're right let's say that
there will be
some intelligent behavior that emerges
from these
huge systems the cloud providers i think
they've given up the
the old-school conception that we should
understand intelligence and they're now
playing the memorization game
they're using their petabyte cloud
storage devices and they're just
basically
memorizing everything but these
functions are extremely large they will
run out of space before anything
interesting happens
all right yeah that's basically what i
was thinking that what you just
described was my belief one year ago
i do not longer endorse that belief
because
along comes gbd3 and gbd3
to me i was like so first of all i was
just like
huh do they not have anything better to
do with their budget and
so i i look into this thing i start
playing with whatever there's this idea
so this
might be a little controversial but i
think it's important to young scientists
out there something i wish someone would
have told me
most of science of doing science is
about
taste it's about having a good
subjective hunch
for what is good what is worth looking
into what is important what's
interesting
the difference between a mediocre
scientist and a really good scientist is
to have a really good
taste and you can disagree with me there
but
i don't think there is a that is that we
wish there was an objective way to
be a good scientist but the reason it's
all about taste and
so when i sat down with gbt3 and i
started experimenting with it whatever
and i read the paper
i i fell out of my chair i was like
jesus christ
if this is the end because and i was
shocked that other people were not
seeing what i'm doing so i i would like
to
try to convey what i felt just like i'm
subjective level so it's
and you could disagree with me
afterwards it's like
fact number one gpt3 did not complete a
full epoch on its data
it saw most of its data only once
but it had such a good wide knowledge
of topics it couldn't have seen more
than once this implies
that it was capable of learning complete
concepts
in a single update step which is
something that everyone keeps
you know saying deep learning can't do
but it seems
that it learned some kind of meta
learning algorithm within its own weight
updates to allow it to rapidly
learn in these new concepts similar to
humans like when you're a baby you take
weeks to learn a single word
but now if i introduced a single new
word to you you would immediately
understand it
it's already learned this hierarchical
and tangled representation
so it's not seeing it for the first time
it's resonating on a path in the network
all these neurons are firing up so my
point is this is very much how humans
live that the
the fact that it became more efficient
in its learning
by having these like reusable structures
like that was shocking to me
is not it learned universal reusable
concepts
to understand speech the same way a
human would have learned
probably and that is that is that was
very surprising to me
and again it's like when i used i make
it i
have a little video game project with a
friend of mine where we it's supposed to
be a gbt
inspire pro powered game it's a dream
simulator so you enter like a key word
and it creates a little dream skate for
you to live to walk around and you
wouldn't be like npcs that talk to you
about your topic or whatever it's a cool
project and
so we used to use gpt2 and
what we had to do for example we wanted
to associate keywords with different
emotions
so if you enjoy cyberpunk you want to be
like dark moody rainy city around like
all these like things we associate with
it
and we had a super complicated idea of
how we put things into like
in into like dictionaries and see like
related words and look up things do all
these complicated things
and then gp3 came around and we just
entered gbt3
what emotions are associated with x and
i'll just tell you
you could just the what what is so
shocking about gp3 is that you could
just
talk to it you just tell gpt you don't
have to formulate a complex close
question or whatever
to for it to fill out you just gbt the
following are characters in
a video game about dream simulations
i'll just output you a list of
characters
you could say the following is a comedy
about you know peter thiel and elon musk
and they'll just output you a comedy
like this happened there it's on i think
it's an aram's blog
and whatever it was a change not just in
quantity but in how
these models could think and do and how
you could
prompt it in a way not think though it's
just a really clever hash table
how do you know can i challenge you on
the on the gpt3 has seen
or learns from like a single update step
it is true that it has seen most of its
training data
only once but it has seen the higher
quality portions
many times and i i haven't seen
a a convincing even single instance
where it is shown that what it learns or
what it outputs
has been only in that particular
training data that it is only seen
once so it's very possible that it does
the many steps on
let's say the things that is seen
multiple times and then just maybe uh
slightly adjusts
slightly connects different things with
the things it only it only sees once
all right yep that is perfectly fair i
like to by the way just
i usually preface this but this is uh
just general i might be wrong
there's always a chance that everything
i'm saying is just absolutely dead wrong
i've been very wrong in the past about
most things i've always
i'm not like like i am so smart and this
is definitely true
i'm just trying to see see how i say how
i perceive this
this is the place for strong opinions
and really evidence to back them up so
exactly we haven't got a clue either but
we spoke to sarah hooker from the google
brain team and she
she said something quite interesting
there's a lot of work around
compression and sparsity and neural
networks and as she was saying that
most of the representational capacity in
the neural network is actually
wasted memorizing hard examples so
what's interesting about whether it's
vision data or language data is that
there are
so many common patterns in the head of
the distribution
and these really strong representations
get established in the neural network
and probably you can delete about 90
of the connections in gbt3 and it
wouldn't even make much difference
potentially i'd like to quickly make the
backup by case about why i think
a gv3 is as intelligent as a human if
that's okay yes
i was going to ask you that yes because
okay it might be a bit of a cop-out
because you might not like the
definition of using here but
here's the fault here's my definition of
what i mean by that i want to clarify
what i mean by that what i mean by that
is
that i expect that if i trained a human
in
similar way in similar tasks i gave them
the same amount of compute i see
i gave them the same amount of things i
expect them to behave to perform
similarly well similar not necessarily
much worse
or much better and because here's how i
visualize the scenario
gpt3 is trained
in a universe of text it has physics its
universe is a 1d
token based universe it has a sense of
physics there is an entropy
to the data that there's a generating
function
of the universe that gp3 is trying to
learn gbd3 is learning a generating
function of a universe
this generating function is the
generating function of english web text
whatever that function might be
and in similar ways humans in the real
world learn a
degenerating function of our physical
universe or an approximation of it
i often see on people on you know in
twitter whatever cough gary marcus carl
saying things like oh look i asked the
agi if i asked ageep3 if a mouse is
bigger than elephant and it said yes
so obviously it's stupid but i think
this is like measuring a fish
fitness by its ability to climb the only
thing the gp3 was incentivized to learn
the only thing it had access to
is this universe of text is it this
physical function of a textual universe
this textual universe correlates with
the real world but it's not the same
as the real world and this is not
different from us humans we do not
perceive the
correct quantum field underlying reality
instead we also
learn a correlated universe of you know
macroscopical phenomena
of colors and objects and stuff like
this this is not reality
nothing that we see is real it's a
virtual environment
that is approximating a real uni the
real universe
and our universe happens to learn so we
happen to learn certain things about our
universe like shape color movement space
and such that do not exist in gpt3s
universe there is no space there is no
time
then there might be time but there's no
space there is no movement there's no
inertia there's no gravity there's none
of these things exist
and so it seems fundamentally flawed to
me
to then to then say oh look
we trained it on x and it didn't learn
why
that's not a counter argument what
you're articulating is that gbt3 is an
auto-aggressive language model
and all it's doing is predicting the
next word and
frankly it's incredible that it does as
well as it does because it seems to have
learned
this implicit knowledge base yes even
though
you've never told it what to do so as a
thought experiment
if you thought it was possible to
generate let's say we had a bert type
model and we could generate because the
problem is we had we have hardly any
training data
what if we could generate a wonderful
corpus which represented a convex hull
over all of the human discourse that
could possibly exist
do you think that would be intelligent
again define intelligent is that for me
intelligent
that's why i talked about compression
i'll say a different way so gbt3 at the
moment
it's rubbish all it does is is produce
coherent text
but it's completely inconsistent yeah it
can write better blog posts than iq
can sometimes oh yeah but it's just the
imitation
it doesn't if you ask it as you said
like any kind of entailment
it'll say that elephants can fit through
doors it's just completely stupid
but here is a conor's defense here
gpt-3 it's not just better than gpt2 it
is
remarkably better it is insanely better
it's one of the few like i i'm not a fan
of the the intelligence explosion
hypothesis but this is probably the best
evidence i've seen
that's even like a feasible thing
it's it's not just that it's doing
better
i i don't think it's intelligent but the
argument that this is a sign that
intelligence may just be a case of
throwing enough parameters and enough
data and enough compute
things like intelligence start to come
into view
in the distant future as opposed to
being like no it's all statistics it's
all
statistics and engineering now it's this
is dicey
no one cares if it's intelligent like as
we said that depends on the definition
of intelligence that's i what scared me
the most in the gpt3 paper
was this straight line of perplexity
no i see it's a log plot but no sign of
slowing down
like no sign that there is ever an end
inside where we can just throw in
10 times more compute and 10 times more
data and we get out
10 times better whatever it is
intelligence
statistical association whatever that is
to the other point and i think it con it
concords with what you're saying conor
and maybe it's a bit what tim wants to
formulate
is the following some if i just train
gpt three on and it's just trained on
the text that exists
it can very well interpolate between
that text and maybe a bit
extrapolate in terms of the patterns
that exist
but if there is any information at all
in that corpus which we can might agree
there is information
that information had to be produced and
it was produced presumably
by humans right maybe not maybe only
0.1 of humans actually contribute any
information other than regurgitating
information that's already there
but all of this information somehow had
to be produced
by some humans so maybe that's what tim
alludes to in a different way and then i
can frame this in in the way you're
formulating is that what the humans do
all they do is just they take the
generating function of the real world
and they regurgitate that and one output
of that is language
right so that's how they produce the
language corpora but
all they do is basically just learn the
generating function of the universe
itself
so you're saying that humans are
generating the data
and gpt3 is learning it and in a sense
that means gpt3 is less intelligent
because
it's it's not exploring or producing
anything new so the volume of the convex
hull is not increasing as people use
gpt3
in fact as soon as it's trained it's
getting old all right before we add more
technical depth can i quickly jump in
here for a few things
yes please so i i
probably explained this very terribly uh
i apologize to any podcast of solicitors
that actually stick through my rants
but one of the few definitions of
intelligence that i also think is very
useful that i like to mention again is
the
definition by jeff hawkins in his book
on intelligence where he defines it as a
kind of being able to predict
which is very related to being able to
compress this brings us to the concept
of
the great look-up table the great
look-up table is a philosophical thought
experiment
is that imagine you had a agent who is
composed
of a lookup table of all possible states
the universe could be
and an intelligent output to it is this
intelligent or not
this is so this is why
computational complexity matters is
there's a lot of fascinating things
about how computational complexity and
reality
are like important like connect there's
lots of things of like how
oh you could go back in time or you
could reconstruct things for a black
hole if you had
exponential compute and stuff like that
those are like weird things that have
been popping up in physics lately
like that and i predict that more of
this gonna happen is that there is a
fundamental like as fundamental as
possible difference
between an algorithm that runs in
polynomial time and run the runs in
exponential
time i think i think i truly believe
that there is a fundamental difference
between them
is that yes if you had a grand lookup
table
that you know has all possible inputs
then and it would act intelligence
whether it be intelligence or not i
think that this is a one of those
questions that is basically incoherent
because constructing such a table is
fundamentally impossible it is
fundamentally
cannot ever possibly be done
there's no way you can construct a table
that's exponentially larger than the
actual universe
like you cannot do that that will never
happen you can speculate about that for
fun
but it's not a but it's it's a it's an
it's an invalid question it's a mouthful
it breaks your assumptions as a point of
order though like surely we
we're basing this entire presumption uh
this entire discussion
of agi basically on asymptotics here on
the assumption that it's possible to
create one of these
objects but it's not provably possible
and so it to say oh it's import may what
if our
artificial general intelligence is the
grand look-up table
you know if one is impossible the other
is impossible no no
i i think i think we need to be careful
about the assertion
of the possibility of these arguments
here's the thing here's the thing
here's where here's where computational
complexity is that the commodore of
complexity
the length of the shortest program that
generates
that table might be small that's
important
the table itself by definition is
exponential in the size of the universe
because it has
every possible state the universe could
be but
it might be that there is a short a
small program
that can generate that table it can be
that the komograph complexity of the
table is small
and then so then it's like the question
assuming i have
this short program assuming i have a
short program that can generate this
lookup table for any
subspace i want for any possible thing
is that not intelligence if that's not
intelligence i don't know what it is
the thing is you have to take into
account the how long will it take for
that program to execute
of course that's that's then that is
like other questions
okay intel intelligence shouldn't really
be measured in comparison to the amount
of compute you give it
so if this comes to compressibility is
in it is
how much can we approximate this this is
perfect grand lookup table how much
how close how convex is the
approximation of these of these
outputs how feasible are them what is
the landscape look like and this is
this is this concept of having structure
in this in space
in the space of policies is that if
everything was random
then the grand lookup table is the only
kind of intelligence that exists
but our universe is not random so we
have other intelligence that can
approximate it to varying degrees to
varying levels and
with much with exponentially smaller
amounts of compute
we could construct all possible go trees
that would be the grand lookup table for
go we could construct that tree but be
so large
that it cannot really exist in our
physical universe but we can make alpha
go
which is a much shorter program a much
smaller program that can still
approximate
to acceptable levels of degree but the
folks at alphago they did what you said
they had a computer program to self-play
and to
essentially create a whole bunch of data
but chalet would say it's not
intelligent because they're
buying skill with unlimited priors and
experience
so what they did was they neural
networks are still sample inefficient
they still had to put loads and loads of
training rounds in there and it it ended
up with this huge neural network
so why is that intelligent okay i guess
we're
i guess we've reached that point where
we have to we have to push the big red
okay we're stretching the definition of
intelligence too far button
and we have to take a step back we're
intelligence is what marvin mincy called
a suitcase word
you could pack all these different
definitions into it and they don't have
to be compatible
so maybe we should try to use different
words here let's taboo the word
intelligence no one is allowed to say
intelligence
for now instead we're going to try to
use different things we're going to use
like sample efficiency we use
computational efficiency finally
performance and and try to see if we can
make the same arguments with those words
sound good yeah that's that would be a
great advice i think for the whole field
which
would have to be restructured into the
subfields of a
artificial sample efficiency and
artificial
yeah but i i think that's a it's a great
it's a great
suggestion just a reminder that we are
often talking
way past each other and then you have
like people ask
me also sometimes for like little
snippets they can put into their
articles like a newspaper or something
is like
but is it really intelligent and
yeah but and i wanna maybe finish off
with a little bit of a connection
to because at the beginning and in
between
you were alluding to things like i don't
care how we make a better world
i i would i i just want it to happen and
so on
and you also alluded to the economy what
we do we're trying to align the economy
and so on
so where do you see or do you see a
large or a small
connection to something like ai ethics
and what people are trying right now to
do
in let's say the real world where we
talk about
banning should we ban face recognition
how much of
our data should go into these algorithms
can we parse out data differential
privacy and so on how much of a
connection
do you see there or how much do you
think general ai alignment research is
disconnected from
these things i have both very flattering
and very spicy things to say about ai
ethics as it currently is practiced
please by definition aia thinks is
obviously a good thing
obviously making ai do more ethical
things that is obviously something that
we want
of course but i am let's say not
super happy with everything how the
field
in practice actually operates this is
not in general there are
wonderful people in this field doing
very important work but i'm not
super happy about how everything is
doing in many ways
ai ethics has become a bit of a
an attempt to solve problems that are
real like
bias and data sets or like using ais to
sentence people unfairly and stuff
that's just of course that should
that's not a good thing
but it's in many ways it is trying is
trying to think of a good metaphor here
it's trying to put out like you're
it's trying to put out your handkerchief
fire while your house is on fire it's
yeah you're right those are problems
but they're not going to solve the house
fire the so like one of the reasons i
don't
work i don't really work much on these
like
common problems of bias text generation
or
deep fakes or something like that is
first of all it's not my comparative
advantage it's not something i'm
unusually good at and
other people are very good and are
working on that and second of all
if we have super powerful agi that's
unaligned it doesn't matter
if we regulate it or not it's just
that's just it just doesn't matter
if we ban we've if the government says
oh ai we forbid you from turning us all
the paper clips
quote by someone who is about to be
paper clipped it's
i think most of these people though
don't believe the agi
or the intelligence explosion is is a
real threat so they are
super focused in on what they perceive
to be the threats to society now
yeah and i understand that i can respect
that i disagree but that's fine but like
that's part of a healthy field
is for different people to focus on
different subjects like they're probably
saying i'm absolutely crazy and they're
going to find plenty of choice bits in
this talk
to show that i'm crazy i'm sure it's you
know and
on this because um yannick was drawing a
corollary between
ai ethics and the alignment problem and
i really like that because we were
talking about that utility function
earlier with the
cauldron and it just it's very human
understandable we have a real problem
with ethics as well that
from a legal framework point of view we
need these hidden attributes and the
levels of discrimination to be
understandable by humans
and chris olive has done more for
machine learning interpretability than
any other person i think in the last few
years
he's got the activation atlas and the
feature visualization articles on
distill which wonderful
he believes that it is possible to
understand
deep learning i i disagree i think that
the whole point of machine learning is
that it does something which we can't
explicitly program
so do you think that's a fundamental
problem that we can only test
we can test the what but we can't
understand the why or the how
yeah yeah i'm very happy chris ola does
the work he does i
think it's really cool but yeah i think
it's i don't think it's gonna work
we have people our discord server
disagree with me who work on
interpretability whatever
but here i base i once saw this great
graph it's like
the the y-axis is like interpretability
and the x-axis is strength of the model
and so it starts really high like simple
models are really easy to understand
and then as it goes up like a little bit
the model is confused they can't really
make good concepts so it's hard to
understand then it goes back up
because the model can make like crisp
clean definitely cut up you know
concepts in a more meaningful way it's
like where humans and where our current
ai systems are
and then it plunges because eventually
it just becomes so intelligent it goes
so powerful
there's just no computationally
reducible way to understand what it is
supposed to do the con
that the i expect that the climatograph
complexity of this officially
intelligent system is just so high
that the amount of compute you need to
exert to understand it
is on the order of actually just running
the system
yeah and this is what rich sutton says
that we need to have massive amounts of
compute but
not only that a lot of these deep
learning algorithms we were talking
about adversarial examples are
features not bugs last week and these
algorithms they learn
just crazy stupid features that that are
present in
as the data presents itself to us as
pixels on a planar manifold there are
these
features that seem to work quite well
that bear no relation to the real world
whatsoever
and then we just memorize those features
on the long tail it's just completely
crazy but it seems to work
yeah i expect more of that to happen in
the future so i'm not super
confident that that interpretability is
a practical way forward because it
always basically puts a limit
on how powerful our agents are allowed
to get at some point just our our agents
might output
a a decision and they might output a
a minimal length explanation but that
minimal length explanation might be so
long
that's just impossible for us to ever
evaluate in a
reasonable time frame and i expect this
to happen you know
sooner rather than later so i don't
think interpretability at least for me
post personally i
don't think is a particularly um
likely way to succeed do you think there
is
there is anything that is
useful or practical from your
perspective that we could do
in terms of let's say regulations or
kind of practices among ai to
to tackle that house fire that you're
talking about like the big alignment
problem
to be clear i am not a policy person so
i'm not going to say anything about like
laws or
regulation because i just don't know
enough about that i'm
skeptical of the utility of those kinds
of processes in general for these kinds
of fast-moving
technically complicated things i'm very
skeptical about that i think government
has
not done particularly well in the past i
hope that could change what i
would wish for is the is basically just
a shift
in the way people think about this
is that it feels to me to a large degree
that many people who go into ai
somehow just never think about what
happens if i succeed
they never seriously consider what
happens if this works
what happens if what happens if
everything goes exactly as planned
what i find i know a lot of people and
some people here have mentioned they're
not fans of the intelligence explosion
but if you think about the intelligence
explosion is the least
weird future that is what is going to
happen if business as usual continues
if completely normal ai progress on the
normal graphs as so far
if nothing unusual happens intelligence
explosions is the default assumption of
what will happen
chaulate and he's my favorite person in
the world but he did write an article um
criticizing the intelligence explosion
he says that intelligence is situational
there's no such thing as general
intelligence your brain is one piece in
a broader system which includes your
body
your environment other humans culture as
a whole no system exists
in a vacuum any individual intelligence
will be both defined and limited by the
context of its existence by the
environment
largely externalized recursively
self-improving systems because of
contingent bottlenecks diminished
returns encounter reactions arising from
the broader context
they cannot achieve exponential progress
in practice
empirically they tend to display linear
or sigmoidal improvement which is what
we see on on here now
so he says recursive intelligence
expansion is already happening
at the level of our civilization but it
will keep happening in the age of ai it
progresses at roughly linear pace so
what do you think about that
i think that yeah you could always make
that argument you could always find
fancy not super defined arguments that
oh it won't happen because it's hard
sure like you fine okay but
it's not about it's not about
i find these arguments very strange i
find these arguments very strange in the
sense that
it doesn't really matter if it you know
grows with this
exponent or that exponent or if it grows
this or that or it takes 50 or 100 years
it doesn't really matter
what matters is at some point it's going
to be strong
it's going to have more you know power
more economic control more intelligence
than all humans put together
and whether that happens now or in 50
years or 100 years or whatever
doesn't really change the core argument
and but if i may
push back just a little bit about it
what actually convinced me
that the intelligence explosion is
definitely going to happen like soon
was actually a very simple thought
experiment it said assume
i make an intelligence as smart as a
human just as smart as a single human
right
it's pretty simple to do let's assume
like we know it must be possible to make
things at least that's smart
takes nine months yeah so let's assume
we make it
yeah we we upload someone's brain we
scan someone's brain whatever doesn't
matter
and now we just run it a million times
faster we just buy a million times more
cpus which is paralyze the thing and run
a million times faster
how is that not super intelligence that
entity
could do a hundred years of thinking in
one hour
but this assumes that virtualization of
a mind
is even possible there's the argument
that if we transfer a human mind into an
octopus
it becomes unrecognizable wittgenstein's
argument about having a conversation
with a lion
no like these are real things our
intelligence
how we perceive intelligence is
fundamentally linked to
not just biology but the systems we
interact with children that are raised
in the wild
they don't ever really come back but
this argument's facetious because it
assumes that intelligence can
even develop in such a way it can even
express itself in such a way yeah
okay but i could say the same thing to
you
is that you assume that it wouldn't is
that the default we don't currently see
anything that hints that there's
anything special about intelligence
there doesn't we haven't yet found any
thing that shows us that any of these
things
these are adding more complexity occam's
razor the simplest possible explanation
is just
every business continues as usual is
that nothing we don't find any magical
part about intelligence
our models and just continue to get
better and better human intelligence is
just an algorithm like any other
that is the default assumption of course
something strange could happen
we can't just assume that we can
virtualize an agent and speed it up
according to moore's law i want to
counter that let's frame it in a way
where it's legal everywhere in the world
you can do certain things to your brain
it's going to be good that will convince
you that you can
speed it up by like a hundred fold at
least
yeah it's called modafinil or
amphetamines
shower simulator 2020. no but that's
this is an interesting point actually
because
smart drugs do not improve your
intelligence they improve your
processing speed
but if you do an iq test after taking a
bunch of modafinil or racetams or
amphetamines or whatever
you will not score better on that
intelligence because you're high
yeah so i'd like to i'd like to clarify
something here
is that if you speed up a brains
processing
you are slowing down time for it it's
that
the if your brain is running it's a
million times speed it has a million
times
more time to think it has a million
times more time
to hang out in the shower but i guess
what i'm saying here is it it
the process like yeah i get where this
argument's coming from
but there seems to be a degree of
detachment and and maybe it's just
we can't even imagine what a non-human
intelligence looks like
but i don't buy this argument that it's
just a matter of waiting for moore's law
to take over there are signs that
moore's law is going to play a role
and certainly a lot of growth but i find
this argument kind of species
even from a biological biological
standpoint it's
a lot of the workings of your nervous
systems are
controlled by these like the myelin
sheathing of your neurons
and we know we there is a giant
correlation between people's iqs
and the kind of quality of their myelin
sheathings which
is directly affecting how
fast signals can travel through your
neurons so
like even in biology it's like
the faster your nerves the smarter you
are
i'm with conor on the if like i see that
if you just speed up a brain it become
more intelligent to an
outside observer well that's just my
opinion
yeah gentlemen we've reached time
connor it's been an absolute honor and a
pleasure having you on on the podcast
thank you so much for joining us i i
feel that we could speak for another 10
hours so we need to have you back on but
seriously thank you so much for coming
on yeah thank you so much yeah so i
would just like to wrap this up with all
saying
is that whether or not you found any of
these arguments super convincing or not
i i would just do
to think about what if we succeed what
if this actually works what if
everything continues as business as
normal
how can we make the world a better place
how can we ensure that humans get what
they want
and that whatever we become in the far
future
the other races of the speed of the
galaxy if they exist are proud of what
we've become
thank you so much for having me amazing
and in passing by the way
connor has a discord server and we'll
put the details in the description so if
you want to
have a conversation with connor about
some of the things we've spoken about
today please join his discord
okay amazing excellent thanks thank you
okay
thank you so much so bye i really hope
you've enjoyed the episode today
remember to like
comment and subscribe and we'll see you
back for a special episode
next week she'll episode next week
she'll episode next week
she'll episode next week she'll episode
next week she'll episode
next week she'll episode next week
she'll episode next week
she'll episode